[Music]
we're watching dc fandom right now and
then the wonder woman 1984 trailer
dropped
we walked away waited for it to go up on
warner brothers
so we're good to watch this now let's do
it so far so good really enjoying the
event linda carter showed up
and they talked about costumes and stuff
yeah a whole lot about the movie but it
was cool it's cool
it's exciting to see them all let's see
the trailer
[Applause]
damn
she has to be swinging on the jet but
just you're not lightning there
okay that's dangerous that's so cool
with that first shot what was she sweet
i look like it was the jet spider-man
complex
okay speaking at the white house
yeah you ain't real steven
wow well that's my turn
at the white house
oh damn
whoa
[Music]
she's like making a helicopter
[Music]
oh
yes oh we gotta look that was
that's great that was delightful that
was great i'm so happy at the moment
this looks pretty freaking epic man i
don't think steve is real
sure maxwell lord something with barbara
minerva's
archaeology background uh they've done
something to trick wonder woman to some
capacity
but from what i'm gathering it's like
maxwell lord he's a telepath
business model and he's at the white
house press conference here
so i think when diana's like fighting
everyone at the white house cause i
couldn't tell from the first shirt like
is she an
enemy now or something yeah but it
sounds like she yeah or sounds like
maxwell lord like manipulated everyone
yeah i mean basically he snuck his way
into the heart
america because you see him at that
press conference doing some crazy stuff
and then it seems like everyone is you
know under his control
and then somehow cheetah's also
factoring
into this i'm i've my i guess my one
skepticism right now is will it fluidly
mesh both maxwell lord and cheated there
because maxwell lord seems like he's
world dominating steaks and then you got
this thing with
cheetah and and kristen wiig looks like
she's doing a great job in this movie
the effects right now i feel like
they'll probably improve by the time we
watch it and especially during the
context of it because
you know there are times you're
adjusting to it for the first time so
they have like super dark lighting right
now yeah
so that way you can like put as much
shadowing effect on it as possible to
make it look as realistic as possible so
looking at it here for the first time
it looks good right now i imagine it'll
look better uh down the road yeah
especially for imax
yeah definitely and i'm just thinking
like well it will it mesh perfectly well
together both storylines when you got
like
world dominating maxwell lord and you
got this very specific
one with cheetah you know it kind of
reminds me of some of the hazards that
like passed
spider-man and i'm sure a lot of other
superhero movies have fallen into where
yeah it's like you have the one
super high stake scenario and then you
have what could potentially be a very
personal
sort of uh conflict yeah or it could be
a distraction if the movie doesn't
handle it right or it could feel like oh
you just shoved this character in to
have
more going on yeah and so basically just
off the strength of the first movie and
everyone who's involved
yeah my hope would be that maybe uh the
story with cheetah and all the
you know everything surrounding that is
a more personal conflict for diana
and and maybe that'll make for a nuance
uh
you know later on down the line as you
know all three of them kind of clash
together in the stakes of the movie or
something
i kind of get a michelle pfeiffer from
uh from batman returns kind of vibe
with her especially because it seems
like they're like they're really close
buds at first or maybe she is just
playing a manipulation game from day
one possibly and then you get to hear
all this stuff with steve trevor looks
like a total blast
i just him trying to adjust it at times
i even love the moment with like the jet
you know
there's radar yeah that's the way i fly
i didn't
consider that and there are moments here
in the church like i love all this stuff
with her swinging on lightning yeah
because all the action looks like patty
jenkins really
upped her game here oh yeah i mean that
whole freeway scene looked like it was
out of yeah some kind of
i don't know christopher nolan yeah but
even in the white house where she's like
spinning the last so it looks like
there's a whole bunch of new lasso
tricks up her sleeve
it looks like they amped up the god-like
side of her powers especially like
that's one thing the lightning moments
made me think of is like yeah she is
like you know
the daughter of god well there that
first shot though
it didn't look like she was swinging on
anything so there's been a lot of rumors
that's like a helicopter thing that she
can do like where the tip spins just
like
super super fast i don't know i'm
playing it back right now
it looks it looks like she's swinging on
something that's invisible in the sky
it could be the jack guys yeah maybe
we'll could be the same
i mean they're in some random new jet
here in the movie steve trevor maybe
they find a way to make it invisible i'm
just saying i feel like
invisible jets gonna show up in this
movie yeah the radar how do we fly under
the radar
come on invisible i'm telling you it's
gonna happen
found an actual radar comment below if
you know the sun just let us know down
below
um but yeah so far i think this looks
like a pretty damn great trailer uh
yeah i mean this looks like it's yeah
throwing down a little bit more on every
element and the co
they talked about the costumes at the
top and while i wish they asked a little
bit more questions during the panel
that were more akin to you know what to
kind of expect out of the movie and yada
yada you gotta ask about characters
because most of the questions were kind
of just like
fun you know like who winning a match in
tennessee
on set memory i got my wig pulled off
but they talked about uh the costume
design
and so them talking about that and at
the beginning of the panel and then
looking at it here especially wonder
woman's costume looks
incredibly bright a little bit more
traditional yeah the golden eagle armor
does look very impressive and obviously
she's
john i'm so sorry
and obviously she's wearing it you know
it's a battle cheetah during this
time yeah she doesn't want to get
scratches for mass
for it's for apex badassery yeah affects
predator versus apex badass
you know what the other thing uh just
that moment where they're uh flying
through the fireworks really reminded me
of that moment from aquaman where
they're
you know failing through and i wonder if
that's gonna become the dc wonder shot
all right guys well i love this one i
liked it more than the last trailer yeah
i like was this is
the last one felt like it was really
hinging on the you know 80s fun
nostalgia and this felt
had a little bit more of that serious
epic scale a little bit yeah
especially with the music can't wait to
see what's in store guys what did you
think of this wonder woman 1984 trailer
you hyped for the film you probably are
anywho subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we got a new youtube
video up especially today
last but not least
maria hammond always giving us some
great stories over and the patreon
messages hits me up a lot
love talking with you my dear and now
she's finally accepted that we will
be giving her shout outs even though
she's declined so get ready maria look
out
because m stands for
motherly a stands for
above average r stands for
righteous i stands for
intense okay an a
stands for
ostentatious is that a word no i it is
a stands for
uh are are you single are you single yet
because uh because we i mean greg's not
but it doesn't matter because uh you
know we both love you we could just you
know we could be polygamous
together aren't you glad that you were
great that we could
give
just kidding thank you maria for being
you you rock my socks
and my underpants it's over okay
[Music]
you